Mọi người mấy mắt của RUB, ông em sợ thông ắm cho biết các cuộc đam phản vì Iran có thể cần thiên và ngay để hoàn tất,
qua đó hả thích khi vọng bệnh, cả năng sớm đá đường thật chấm rất xung đồ đảo giao dài đơn bà tháng 2.
Pháp yêu việc rưu dài trong đối cạnh của đồ Mỹ tiếp tục mở các đồ không kết nhằm bảo bệ phòng tiên lửa,
và tấu Iran bị gà buộc trên khá thi lối gần ở bên Hômut.
Washington, Múa ta, đây là hành động tư vẻ nhằm bảo bệ lực lượng Mỹ,
và bảo đam đường hả chỉ lực này và được mở lại bằng cách này hả các cá.
Theo hãng tổn rời tư vẻ Iran đã đạt một số tiến chiến trong việc xây dừng bản giữ nhớ bà đồ,
nhằm chấm rất rao trang và khuộc phục phòng đồng bất tài của bệnh hômut,
trước khi bước sáng dài đoạn đảm phản xô hơn về chú chính hành nhân của Tehran,
cho khi đó Iran tưu bữa bảo lưu quyền đáp trả mọi hành vi vi phản ngân bán,
các ngủ tiên Iran cho biết, chừng gà lưu của công,
khiến lập ở đây, giải phòng khoảng 20 tư tiên,
đô là Mỹ tại sang của Tehran, bị phòng khoảng, nương ngoài.